hey guys it's Jonah here how's your
eating habit going I hope that you're
seeing some progress and what I'll be
doing in this video is to actually film
my mail plan for a day this is really
for you to have an idea on what I eat
what time I eat how often I eat portion
size as well as calories count in a meal
you don't have to follow my meal plan
but this is really just a guideline for
you to eat healthy loose weight as well
as to maintain your weight the point is
you need to love your food love what you
eat and not feel like you're being
restricted so always remember trying to
keep 80% of the food in a day healthy
and the 20% you can solve lie mix it up
with something that you like but don't
go overboard so let's see what I eat in
a day I don't know what I eat in a day
but we'll find out morning guys I've
just woken up it's breakfast time
my hair is too messy I'm still you know
in my pajamas but I always have my
breakfast within 1 hour of me waking up
because if I have my breakfast wrong my
whole day is ruined so I'm just gonna
show you what I have
most days where it's really simple but
it keeps me going and it keeps me
energized
so guys I've got my slice of toast I am
only using one toast for breakfast today
it's because I've got a thick slice
where it's this one slice it's about 125
calories
therefore I'm only using one slice but
if I were to buy the Norma's medium thin
slice
that's about 60 calories per slice and
then I would prefer to use 2 slices of
toast so for today because it's thick
I'm only using one slice of whole new
toast and I've got my green tea I always
have my greens in the morning without
fail I love my green tea in a big big
mug so that's my green tea that's my
drink I've got my egg that's my protein
I'm gonna poach this egg and so I've got
my jam which is I'm gonna spread it on
my toast I've chosen basically a no
added sugar Jen because it tastes much
better
very very much better and it's more
delicious and it's healthier as well
because there's no added sugar inside
all you get is the pure sugar and pure
sweetness from the fruit itself so I'm
going to prepare a breakfast now and I'm
gonna show you the end result ok
that's my breakfast I've decided to
slice into half half I spread it with
jam and another half I top it with well
this is almost like Huff boy cake and so
it's full of protein and carbs and also
I usually have a piece of fruit in the
morning it doesn't have to be origin can
be an apple can be anything that you
like because it's just so refreshing and
it's really nice to have a fruit in the
morning I mean I like it so I'm gonna
have my breakfast now and I'm gonna hit
to the Ginsu hey guys so it's morning
right now it's snack time and I've just
got back from the gym so I'm feeling a
little bit hungry and I'm gonna make
myself something quick which is banana
smoothie really simple only two
ingredients bananas and milk and we're
going to blend it up and that's it
really simple healthy but it's delicious
I love bananas so let me show you how
it's done
I've got my frozen bananas here
basically what I've done is I've sliced
two bananas up and I've put them in the
freezer overnight and so this is now
ready to be blend there for your banana
smoothie it's gonna be ice cold without
having to blend any ice or crush any ice
and I've got your ordinary milk if you
don't like milk you can use soya milk
I'm gonna put this too in the blender
right now and just blend it up simple as
that
this blender here is my favorite blender
is my best investment I would say it
only cost me I think about 20 pounds
when I bought it and it was on the
discount I love it it's because you know
it all you need to do is basically put
your ingredients in here and literally
cover it up literally just cover it up
and it's ready to be blended so yeah let
me show you
I know we're just gonna add about 200
ppm facu just to slash your second in so
now that's going to go on for about one
to two weeks and I'll never see
[Music]
so let me show you what it's like it's
really thick basically can you see it
it's really thick and creamy and all
this is just banana and milk and it's
delicious so that's two bananas and 250
ml of milk and that gives you about 500
milliliters of banana smoothie and what
I love about this blender smoothie to go
blender as well is it comes with the top
so what I can do now is just to cover it
up and bring this out with me and I'm
like I'm not gonna bring it on with me
today but I'm gonna have it as my
post-workout smoothie and that's my
second today it's delicious and it's so
simple all right I'll see you for lunch
mmm so good
hey guys so it's lunchtime now and
because I'm in a rush today as I have to
go for a meeting later on I'm gonna prep
something that is really quick simple
and healthy and at the same time it
burns me up and you can even do this in
the morning before you go to work and
pack your lunch to work so what I'm
preparing right now is just simple
tuna sandwich but it's really healthy
because it's full of protein and it's
delicious I love tuna I love tuna so
let's see you let's see how I do it I've
got my tuna here I've chosen spicy tuna
because I love spice and that's one kind
of tuna but we're only going to be using
half a can of tuna for lunch and I've
got my carbs that's your protein
basically and I've got my cards my bread
my sandwich bread and that's only 100
calories I've also got my you know
delicious carbs full of fiber my baby
carrots and my corns I love baby carrots
in almost all of my meals I will always
have baby carrots in and I've got my
healthy low-fat delicious grated cheese
fat so simple what I'm gonna do is just
to you know spread the tuna on my bread
really quickly
[Music]
so that's my house can of tuna and
literally all I'm gonna do is just
spread cheese on top of it and you can
eat it straight away like this if you
want to and as I've also said you can
also just you know put it together
stylish it together and pick it up for
lunch this is me being really really
lazy and having no time okay but instead
what I'm going to do is I'm just gonna
you know live it on the grill for a
while just to allow the cheese will melt
and to quit my vegetable little bit as
well
[Music]
and you see that it's oops can you see
that it's slightly toasted and the
cheese that slightly melted that's
basically how I like my food it's
slightly toasted a slightly burned it's
right guys so that's my very simple and
healthy lunch I've got my protein which
is my tuna I've got my card which is my
bread and my fiber cards as well which
is my vegetables and I've got a little
bit of fat which makes the put even more
delicious which is my low-fat cheese
it's really simple remember it takes
less than five minutes and it's really
good for a quick lunch do this at home
don't say you don't have time because
this is really simple so guess I'm just
in cluster right now wait till you bring
it up with my friend Ernie
yeah
I've chosen to have a cup of americano
and together with some work here as well
so that's my medium cup of americano and
it's very very messy background so if
you have no choice but to meet someone
in a copy place try to offer a healthier
option but if you do want to go for your
cappuccino latte or mocha which is my
favorite try to go for the skinny option
yeah and too much but yeah hey guys so
it's dinner time right now and I'm just
so tight right now to be honest but that
doesn't give me a reason to eat crap so
I'm going to be preparing a really
simple dinner grilled salmon lightly
stir fried vegetables and also a small
cup of brown rice because they nation we
need our eyes so instead of having white
rice go for brown rice because it's
healthier for you and instead of deep
fried stuff choose to grill it okay so
I'm gonna prepare it right now and I'll
show you the finished product right guys
so what's what dinner
ooh it's too money you can actually see
the smoke coming out I've got grilled
salmon I like to grill my food because I
don't have to do the job it's literally
you know put in a grill and it will be
done in five to ten minutes and I've
topped it with a little bit of cranberry
sauce I like cranberry sauce vegetable
lightly stir fried green vegetables and
my corn and also a half cup of brown
rice and not forgetting my fruits orange
yeah as you can see I've eaten two of
them so I've got orange and my main meal
that's what dinner tonight very easy
very quick very simple but it smells
good and it's making me hungry so I'm
going to eat
so guys that's pretty much what I eat in
a day as you can see a small portion but
very frequently so by the end of today
I've I mean by the end of this dinner I
would have eaten five meals
don't say that you don't have time to
get all of the meals I've done today
it's really simple and quick and also
what I tend to do is that I tend to
prepare more food extra food basically
at you you know keep it away keep it in
the fridge and therefore I can have it
the next day if I know like for example
tomorrow I'm gonna have a busy day busy
day so I tend to prepare our extra food
to keep so that I don't have to do the
cooking again today and that's usually
what I do to the fight you know just
grabbing and buying food as from outside
and you don't know what goes into the
food but basically that's what I eat in
a day you don't have to always stick to
fish you can change it you know whatever
I eat you can always change you for
another source of protein for example
you know they need or tofu anything
that's perfect but not processed food so
yeah and always try to keep your food in
your cupboards so that you don't see it
visually if you see something the
tendency is you would take it and eat it
if you don't see it chances are lower so
I hope you've learned something and I'm
going to have my dinner now
[Music]